the european commission has created a
set of online tools to help you get
going with levels the eu approach to
assess and report on the sustainability
of buildings first there's an e-learning
program hosted on the eu academy
platform it's the best place to start
when preparing to use levels in your
working environment the e-learning
program is designed for all kinds of
built environment professionals and
shows you how to apply levels at all
stages of a building's life cycle it's
fully customizable too
so whether you're involved in the
planning design financing or completion
of the building the levels e-learning
program is for you
the program also includes a case study
exploring how each levels indicator can
be used throughout the life cycle of a
building step by step you'll see how you
can cut emissions save natural resources
and improve occupants quality of life
the aim is to give you the knowledge and
motivation to complete your first
building assessment using levels
as well as the e-learning program levels
offers a free calculation and assessment
tool making it easier to measure
sustainability performance on your
project you can use the tool to create a
project and start an assessment
choose your indicators complete your
assessment and compare your assessment
results
we hope these resources will help make
your building project more sustainable
access the e-learning program and
calculator tool today through the levels
website